here we are at our media okay so i think
i'll let people introduce yourself yes
they are dad huggy show gay hey chill
now let's see come tomorrow there are no
lon tengo el numero another to angelo
honda and maybe we've has this look at
but you know what we'll do we pass it
around urban Sonnen Jeremy Rohani dad to
hang googas or some young pan come on
Sarkis on the day I'm google 9 guaco hey
Emily no mucho seen it up I'm California
okay I don't know what else to say this
thing I just got shoved a camera the
past is over to these two korean girls
here who are not quite ready for it
give me that my love is all about
hi everyone I'm Alan I'm from Brazil I'm
in Korea almost two years i'm currently
studying on international studies nice
to meet you all my career hello my name
is Brandon lifting Korea for two years
I'm an English teacher and I'm studying
Korean I've been watching Steve for the
last two or three years he's been an
inspiration
now that's about it to introduce the
group here a very jolly group and now
I'm going to get back to eating
otherwise they'll get ahead of me in
there to be no food that were shown the
booth oh yeah we gotta show this there
we go what is it call her some girl time
you know the three-layered meet and what
do you do describe it was a
demonstration yes go to the girl so you
don't hear gotta cool it shows people
are not talking to me lettuce garlic get
piece of meat off the grill like this
put it in the lettuce hopefully it's not
too hot wrap it up I could hear there at
all okay and on that note I'm get back
to eating